[Musique]
le monde n'a toujours été que chaos et
des illusions mais enfin un bar
la nature m'a fait un don
voir que j'ai toujours dû cacher jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
depuis quelques jours le chaos règne
parmi la population
le prêcheur avait empoisonné les stocks
alimentaires il n'est pas juste le chef
de la mafia
il tient les médias
[Musique]
et ils recrutaient avec chaque jour plus
nombreux
[Musique]
pour certains c'est un dieu
il est temps de révéler votre vraie
nature
qui a fait ça quelqu'un qui se prend
pour un héros grec storm
tu crois pouvoir sauver ces gens
mais tu ne peux rien contre noir
vous êtes le seul à pouvoir l'arrêter
je vais débarrasser le monde des gens
comme toi